how do you know that readiness
equals performance have you done studies
do you
have anything inside the company where
you work with universities or
do actual laboratory experiments to know
that readiness
is like actually a valid you know
number yeah and what and how do you do
that i guess so i think a question
yeah um and at some point we'll connect
the rest of the dots and how it got to
the company but
i think you're starting to see it
already um readiness
um a couple things one you look at the
theory right
so there's lots and lots of good science
papers and theories saying
hey your hrv changes your resting heart
rate changes or if you get six hours of
sleep
um you know so resting heart rate is
when i'm asleep
correct we look at it when you're
sleeping um
and your lowest resting heart rate and
then we look at that why is
lowest resting heart rate so important
physiologically
and also a little bit with the autonomic
nervous system you know the vagus nerve
that connects your brain
and your body um your lowest resting
heart rate is something that requires
both physical and mental relaxation
so you typically reach like you know if
you're the research shows that if you're
actually
well recovered and well rested in sort
of a you know
normal pattern you'll reach your lowest
resting heart rate sort of midway
through the night
right now if you're super stressed
you're working super late or you worked
out late or you drank or you ate a ton
of food
your resting heart rate will actually
happen much later uh you know you
it'll have it'll take you seven eight
hours to process that alcohol
so digestion like alcohol getting in a
fight with your spouse
your boss yells at you or you got a big
project tomorrow that could actually
keep you away from the lowest heart rate
resting heart rate
correct yeah it's just a sign of stress
and then same
same with heart rate variability right i
think heart rate variability
is is a great measure the autonomic
nervous system um that's sort of showing
this
you know stress on your your you know
your central nervous system on your body
and your brain
and so i think those two are really
important to look at
um and then sleep you know we you know
we do think that it's not just one night
a bad sleep
um you know it's a compounding night's a
bad sleep that really hits you
and then also you know if you've been
inactive if you're less active than
normal or even more active
right you're going to be tired like hey
you just ran a marathon you know
that's that's a lot yeah it's just three
or four days of your body
feels like you got hit by a mack truck
so the heart rate
variability that's something we've just
been able to start capturing on these
devices whether it's an apple watch
fitbit or aura
correct this is a new sensor or the
sensors have become precise enough to
pick this up
the latter yeah so heart rate
variability is is actually
the variation in every single heartbeat
so united time between them is how is
explained to me
correct yeah the inner beat interval is
is you know think about it sort of
you know your heartbeat over time is you
know look like a sinusoidal wave pattern
right
and so you know time is sort of on your
x-axis right
and if you think about that the space
between each beat
if we're sitting here taping this
podcast and our 60 beats per minute
that's the average over the minute
now the question is what's the
variability within that minute
right and and that is heart rate
variability
less variability and more consistency
is better opposite it's counterintuitive
yeah so actually you want more
variability
wow why would
more be better or do we not know um so
the
i think theoretically maybe i can
explain it physiologically speaking so
when you're in a
high variation a high heart rate
variability you can sort of adapt to any
situation
so part of your body's functions is like
imagine like we're sitting here and all
of a sudden like
you know a cheetah jumps in the room
right what do you need to do right fight
or flight you need to
drop everything you know you need to
push you know nick to the ground and you
need to make
you know hall fort right so to get nick
right unfortunately
right but for you to respond that way
you need to be in a little bit of a flow
state you need to have the variation
so high variability right allows you to
react and adjust quickly from both your
mind and your body and not
freeze now if you are you know if you're
really sort of anxious and stressed it's
like every little thing irks you
right um and that like you're actually
you feel like rigid you feel like stuck
your heart rate is actually very very
you know that energy interval is very
consistent
whereas like heart rate variability when
it's different
it makes you more nimble it's better
cardiovascular
ability maybe more resiliency because
you're you're dealing with many
different situations
kind of like cross-training or a lot of
different fitness theories are
you don't want to just do four exercises
you want to try 400 different exercises
and get all different types of movement
going on your body
precisely i think the best thing i heard
on that do you know what the best
exercise in the world is
have you heard walking no no it's the
one you're not doing
right oh what a great yeah yeah so you
want that you want that ability to
attack but no
you know it's interesting there's a
whole philosophy of working out which is
for guys who get older um or anybody who
gets older i suppose but i was listening
to it on the
this is the maybe we saw tim favorites
or something that they try to get older
men
to try new exercises crawling on the
ground
moving balance beams just anything
different
so that your mind and your body gets
just better at
adapting and when you don't you get this
negative cycle of totally being at your
desk
all the time but at some point